joining us right here from nfl live i
also enjoy listening to him call games
uh on the college football weekend our
friend dan orlovsky from espn back here
on the show how are you dan
i'm doing good rich you're good back
good to be back with you man how are you
doing i'm doing great thanks uh i'm i'm
i'm just got a ton of questions for you
i'm just gonna jump right into it what
do you see when you look at the chiefs
what's going on do you think
when you see him a lot of issues um what
are those issues number one there's
there's a lack of commitment
to running the football we all know that
um do i think they're great at it no but
the lack of commitment to actually
calling runs this is a
an offense that has
made its foundation the rpo the run pass
option
when you do that there are negative
consequences to that for both units and
players your offensive line does not
fire off the football
like it would if a run just a run play
was called they no longer are obsessed
with moving people off the line of
scrimmage
candidly they can't really try to drive
people past three or four yards because
if patrick pulls the ball on the rpo and
throws it that's going to be a flag so i
think there's been a
slow deterioration in the mindset
of an offensive lineman
i think number two
patrick mahomes feet have absolutely no
rhythm to that um i'm doing this on nfl
live today breakdown yep i think patrick
mahomes mechanically right now is the
worst quarterback in the nfl
um
let me let me i'm not trying to be a hot
take or hyperbolic here i'm completely
aware of who i was as a player and i'm
completely aware of who patrick is
um patrick's most talented player i've
ever seen at that position in my life i
also want don't want to pretend like
patrick was
drew brees like he was this tactician
this technically
you know um
perfect player he's always been a
poor mechanic or freelance mechanic
player he has never been who he is right
now inside the pocket
his feet mechanically
are so bad right now it is having such a
negative impact on
the pocket presence the accuracy
the
rhythm of a play
um there's multiple examples last night
and it has slowly started to present
itself and deteriorate and i thought
last night was even more of a
culmination
there are still moments of good results
yet there's a bad process when it comes
to that
um
you know they haven't really developed
the number two wide receiver outside of
tyrique tyrique kelsey's the tight end
that's one and two pass catchers but
there's no number two wide out
um so
you know it's not just a single thing
rich um do i think there's fixable
aspects to it
absolutely
um absolutely i think that andy reid
eric the enemy mike kafka and patrick
mahomes have earned the right
for patience so to speak and belief and
trust in it but that's just the reality
right now that was my follow-up about
how fixable things are because you know
obviously it is the longest regular
season ever we keep hearing that we're
now have
reaching right around the halfway point
there is an extra game of runway uh
unfortunately that extra game of runway
for patrick mahomes that 17th game is
coming up this week it's green bay so
you run out of time for patience and
trying to fix stuff that is fixable
how quickly is this stuff fixable in
your estimation yeah i i don't think the
mechanical stuff is fixable in season
i think that's really difficult can you
make it better yes do i think you can
get rid of it no i mean that is a
that is a commitment to the off-season
type of thing for me um but i think they
can get him better on it as long as they
emphasize it and he emphasizes it and
really works at it the reality is
you only practice three days a week
right and so maybe it's one of those
things and this is what i would be
trying to sit down and have a
conversation
we got to sit we got to come in on
monday and tuesday and work on some of
this stuff give me 30 minutes give me an
hour i just
for me that's what i would try to be
talking about um i've been pounding the
table that you know i would call more
check with me more than rpos check with
me zar you call two plays in the huddle
one could be a run one could be a pass
you want to get the line of scrimmage
and they're gonna play you in those two
high safeties let's run it the offensive
line we are not throwing it until you
hear me go check check alert alert apple
apple whatever that is the check with me
and if they drop down to safety and play
one high well then we could throw the
football and i think
that would be a benefit for their
offense um the turnovers and penalties
are i don't think
that's who they are this year right now
that's just who they are and they're
going to have to try to overcome that
and and kind of
really hone in on some of the other
execution aspects to kind of mask it so
to speak dan arlovsky here on the rich
eyes and show you could check out more
of dan's opinions of patrick mahomes
footwork and what's fixable and what's
not later on nfl live on espn he's on
the rich eisen show right here what do
you think's going through sean payton's
mind uh about who's the starter
uh not just for this week with it looks
like um taysom hill on course to return
from a concussion uh or for the rest of
a season that appears to be
flat out in the mix for the division and
for a run in the nfc i mean the saints
are coming on strong
this is a season that is not lost what
do you have for me on this dan what do
you think yes
sean payton's track record and the
empirical data we have on ship sean
payton says that he's going to be pretty
darn good and so were the saints no
matter who his quarterback is
um you know he's got one we got 20 games
of sean payton as the head coach of the
saints without drew brees
he's in 19 games excuse me he's 16 and
six without drew okay so
drew's a hall of famer you're not going
to get that production out of the
quarterback
but this the backbone of this football
team
roster wise is a hands-on
sticky defense
that is not changing and then a very
good offensive line so i look at it as
saying
trevor siemian if we were going to point
to one thing that he could not do that
is his fatal flaw so to speak it is
having to move having to go above the
x's and o's having to go create
well with a dominant offensive line or a
really good offensive line and a lights
out play caller you don't really need
that as a quarterback
i need you and sean payton needs trevor
simeon to go and be really good with his
decision making get the football to
alvin kamara and michael thomas who's
coming back marquez callaway who's
coming on
i think they move forward trevor simeon
because of that because of the offensive
line and because of sean payton and i
still think that they can be a good
football team i don't think that this is
a super bowl run football team and still
therefore i don't believe that adding
drew brees back or phillip rivers or cam
newton or trading for nick bowles
changes that
i think this is a team that can be a
good football team and be in the mix
come december with trevor simeon because
of the backbone being the defense in the
offensive line can you do me a favor and
put into words best you can from your
experience uh with what simeon was able
to do in the middle of a game mike white
getting a start um for the first time in
his career um also cooper rush not
knowing really if he's gonna start until
the last minute and then he wins
his first career start how difficult is
that to do
dan yeah it's there's certain aspects of
it that are incredibly challenging
because you're waiting for the moment
you don't know when it's going to come
specifically for a guy like cooper rush
and mike white
those those later round draft picks guys
that have been tossed around or
undrafted for agents you know greg olson
who's the offensive coordinator for the
las vegas raiders was my rookie year
quarterbacks coach
and he said something to me my rookie
year that
forever changed my football time but
also like my life so to speak
you don't know when the opportunity is
going to come
don't look back and regret that you
weren't ready
and i think that's what we saw with some
of those players is you don't know when
the opportunity is going to present
itself and so you got to be impatiently
patient you have to maniacally work and
prepare like it is going to be today and
believe it's going to come because when
it does you get one shot as one of those
late round guys you get one moment to go
all right this guy doesn't stink and
we'll give him another chance and you've
just got to be so ready and prepared for
it i think what you saw specifically
with mike white and cooper rush was
those guys have sat and watched and sat
and learned and had mental rep after
mental rep after mental rep for
thousands of mental reps and so when
they had to go on the field and play
they knew what to do with the football
for the most part i thought that both
their mindsets were i'm not going to
lose the game you know and i've heard
steve young say that so many times as a
backup quarterback don't lose the game
mike white
go watch the tape he just did a really
good job of taking easy throws he threw
to the backs 20 times
just hey you guys go on your scholarship
go on your paycheck so to speak cooper
rush you know again didn't do anything
to hurt the football team outside of
that one interception
and even then the deep so i just think
those guys
you know were ready for the moment did
not try to be something that they're not
and we're just very good with making
sure that they did the simple things at
a high level i saw my own two eyes it's
so far this weekend where the
the patriots were daring
daring justin herbert to check it down
right they were like go ahead you know
like this is what we're we're not going
to let you go deep mike williams is not
going to beat us
you know you need to be patient and and
the the quarterback who did that and
then took his shot waited for guys to
come clear on the second level was mack
jones he was spectacular dan
he was spectacular again it's unreal
what's happening yeah
rich i think mac jones is the best
quarterback rookie wise i've ever seen
when it comes to knowing where to throw
the football
when to throw the football and how to
throw the football
he's just i've said i said this when i
started looking at him i called his game
last year
he just has this incredible ability to
play so fast and
i think for many reasons why is because
he was the scout team quarterback in
alabama playing against that alabama
defense for two years you better learn
to play real fast when you're playing
against the starting defense for alabama
there's two plays in the second half
that are the
phenomenal imagery of this
one is he does a play-action pass it's
the jacoby myers meyer starts on the
right side of the formation and he's got
like this little six or seven yard
shallow cross for the left side and it's
a play action it's in the fourth quarter
on really that game ceiling drive so to
speak
and he ends up being
basically wide open after the play
action and matt just kind of floats this
ball out there becomes this 20 yard
completion
go re-watch it because matt comes out of
the fake flips his head around and he
puts his right foot back foot in the
ground
right when that right foot hits the
ground that ball comes out of his hands
floated to space on the shallow cross if
he waits two tenths of a second takes a
fraction of the hitch or just as a blink
slower he's going to get hit from his
left side
the backside defensive end it is going
to be a sack fumble and there's three
chargers there waiting to pick up that
fumble that is something that it doesn't
show up in a box score but it's a
game-changing play and it's because the
young man knows
when to throw the ball where to throw it
and how to throw it at such an
incredibly high and efficient level
right now that their offense
doesn't really have moments of um
you know sputtering they're just really
really
efficient right now
he takes what he take and then he has no
problem throwing it away i i i was
really impressed with what i saw uh
last one for you dan in the couple of
minutes i have left with you dan olofsky
of espn uh how impactful is the von
miller acquisition
because obviously this is the ram saying
we're going to win now he's not under
contract for next year this is the
ultimate the ultimate admission even
though we've gotten the sense of it with
everything else that they've done this
is it right now they got they got the
quarterback they've got the back end
they got the front end they got bobby
trees they got cooper cup they've got
daryl henderson they got that line
they're ready
how impactful is von miller in your
estimation
it's huge uh the way i phrased it is
this is about getting through the
playoffs not getting to the playoffs for
the los angeles rams this is that four
or five game stretch because they know
who they gotta play when they get to the
dance they're playing the dallas cowboys
and they're playing the tampa bay
buccaneers and they're playing the green
bay packers and they're playing the
arizona cardinals
you better be able to get after the
quarterback and not
kind of succumb numbers on your back end
you better be able to bring four or five
and still be playing coverage now
something the rams have started to do
that they did a little bit last year
midway through the season they're taking
aaron donald and leonard floyd and
putting both those guys right next to
each other basically on a tackle outside
of one of the offensive tackles aaron
donald head up and then leonard floyd
outside of him and then they're putting
a different defensive lineman on the
center's head right above the center's
face right when rich has an offense when
those guys do that and i got donald
employed on one side and i got to throw
the football crazy they got a person
over the center's head i've got to take
four people and send them that way i
have to because leonard and aaron are
all the way outside and i gotta help the
center
von miller's gonna be away from that i
gotta bring four i only got five that
means von miller is gonna be one on one
a lot and i don't need vaughn to win
like he did in 2015 30 times a game i
need him to win five times in those
passing situations and i think that's
exactly what they're playing with von
miller is wow man that's the only thing
i could say is i'm like laughing
listening to you say that that is really
wild that's how impactful uh hey man
thanks for the time greatly appreciated
what game you doing this weekend
what are you doing i have oklahoma state
and west virginia a lot seven and one
oklahoma state they're good football
team so i'm excited for it all right
you're calling mcafee to do your
research is that what you got is that
what you're gonna do yeah i'm actually
i'm actually demanding that that could
be joining the booth i think it's gonna
be a hard no but we'll see okay thanks
dan really appreciate it let's do it
again thanks brother yes sir thank you
you're the best dan orlovsky makes me
smarter hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here